how did I end up sitting on top of a
blinken's head well strap yourself in
for one hell of a ride
[Music]
so I spent the last couple of weeks with
the most intense creative block and now
I finally feel back to my old soul I
think last week's film which I'll
annotate to the end of this film really
helped unblock that whole situation it's
a really shitty place to be and if you
there maybe watch that phone and I hope
you resolve some of those creative
issues but for now I'm sitting on a
ferris wheel in a place called Maryland
why well let me start like this I have
this idea no wait I have this really
ambitious idea I found my dear book from
five years ago with the goal to create a
film so ambitious have to change the
perception of millions of people around
the globe I'm gonna make this book first
I need the right location something as
purposeful as vibrant and enthusiastic
as the idea itself
[Music]
this is an ambitious than Africa what is
ambitious at Watertown
[Music]
this idea is just so you know I need a
location that really captures that
ambition is one of the most irritates
and emotions before the sixteenth
century it was actually considered a
negative character traits but now it's
known as the emotion that makes up one
part of the term passion the other being
love for me ambition is like rage
still not good enough at 8:00 p.m. on
Saturday night it was missing with rain
and I'd yet to find anything ambitious
enough I was still completely convinced
on making this happen but I realized I
was thinking inside the box of a mess
like why not mission further I found
this picture of the president's heads
and rumor they had been dropped to some
dudes farm lands in the middle of
Virginia I thought to myself you can't
find a location that encompasses more
ambition right I called up my mates
[Music]
[Applause]
played the Lord and lost hope twice
[Music]
omitsu rad guys on the scooter bonded
over and watched the Sun Rise then we
arrived at the spot Google Earth reckons
that this is where we needed to park the
car and now we're gonna hit into the
forest we've got to make our way through
there you already know I've found the
heads because I put it in the intro so
I'm gonna cut the anticipative turn and
use this walk to give context to the
idea when I think of the world we live
in I think of a term called WTF why the
fail what's wrong with the world
I see people huddled up in cliques I see
the period we living in as the era of
disconnect
I see people too afraid to speak their
mind as they may come across as
offensive or demeaning about some
minority sect I see a world of
self-diagnose defenders I see a world of
beautiful content hidden behind senses I
asked a question why we continually
search for negative motives giving no
space for the good to speak freely now
you may have many answers to this but
this is my mind so therefore stop
listening to answer and start listening
to understand that I'm not making this
movie because I'm trying to tackle some
minority or stand on a hand-me-down
white privilege pedestal with a golden
spoon in my mouth to preach no I have an
idea that will showcase a world of
beautiful people that will give voice to
the unsung heroes the hidden gems
stoners
[Music]
if you told me yesterday that I'd be
standing next to Abe Lincoln's head
right now I'd have told you your lines
ambitions of anything I didn't know
exactly what I was looking for but I
knew I was looking for something great
therefore I just didn't stop pushing
until I found it and here we are okay so
the idea the phone I need you very
literally I need 104 makers from 100
different countries around the world to
create this piece with me let me explain
I've written something that's too
special to make a learn too diverse for
single man's knowledge to globally
spread to possibly accomplish in time
too beautiful not to share this week's
film is a call to action to get those
filmmakers involved every single person
is welcome from every nook and cranny
around the globe if you're not a
filmmaker reach out to one in your
village your city your neighborhood
email me on brew at Danvers calm to get
involved in this project together we are
going to create the most honest and
diverse phone around
my mission with this YouTube channel is
this I bought this book about eight
years ago called humankind and I changed
some of the words to make sure that it
wouldn't feel off my path as a creative
Dan mace doesn't make people empty
short-term promises he encourages
authentic emotional long-term
relationships between his films and the
people who watch them this is the
starting point of a really honest
relationship I'm going to be really busy
working on this big film as well as the
three six eight films which you can
watch daily obviously on Casey's channel
so therefore I'll be taking next week
please send through your emails and then
I'll explain everything over email on
email if you really serious about this
project I'm super super amped about this
one as always please subscribe if you
like my movies if you haven't already
and like and share and tweet me oh yeah
you can also follow me on Instagram and
Twitter for the week that I'm gone
I always keep up to date
[Music]
[Music]